الان على الشعب الاوكراني ايضا اثبت يعني
خلال هذه الفتره عن وحده كبيره وهو يحضن
الجيش الاوكراني والاداره الرئاسيه يعني
انا كنت متفاجئ منذ الفتره منذ بدايه
الحرب حول الالتزام الكبير يعني مثلا يمنع
اثناء القيام في ضربات صاروخيه يمنع تصوير
مكان سقوط الصواريخ وهذا يسبب نحن حتى
اعلاميين نريد الحصول على اماكن سقوط
الصواريخ هناك تكتم كبير في بعض الاحيان
لا يتم ابناءنا ولا نستطيع الحصول على
معلومات فقط عبر مصادر
خاصيه محمد ربما قد تعطي همم العدو
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا معلومات همم واحداثيات
لا تريد ان تكشف عنها
نعم بالفعل بالفعل وايضا يعني يتداول ان
روسيا تقوم بخرج شبكات الاتصالات الوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي للحصول على مراكز تواجد
الجيش الاوكراني بالامس مثلا الجيش
المخابرات الاوكرانيه القت القبض على
شخصين كانه في في شرق اوكرانيا يكومان
بتصوير وتحديد مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه
لتكون روسيا بقصفها بالمدفعيه ايضا الجانب
الاوكراني حصل على معدات تكنولوجيه متطوره
تستطيع تحديث او تشويش على شبكات
الافرازات ومعرفه الاشخاص الذين يقومون
وتحديد اماكن الجواسيس كما يسموهم في
اوكرانيا الذين يقومون بايصال المعلومات
الروسيه والمخابرات الروسيه
متداوله لاستهداف محطه كهرباء في كييف
بضربه صاروخيه روسيه نشاهدها الان امامنا
على الشاشه يبدا ان هناك دخان يتصاعد من
هذه المحطه الكهربائيه في العاصمه كيف
محمد يعني سنبقى مع كتابه عن في اي جديد
حول هذا القص كنت تتحدث عن غضب السكان اثر
عدم يعني اعطاء روسيا فرصه لسكان في
اوكرانيا للاحتفال براس السنه واعياد راس
السنه صحيح محمد
يعني في هذه الاوقات في الايام العاديه
يحتفل السكان تكون هناك حركه كافيه كثيره
في وسط كياب في المجمعات خاصه